يبدو الأمر كما لو أننا قد تم إلقاؤنا أو شيء من هذا القبيل كما
ترى دولًا أخرى تقوم بإجلاء
مواطنيها، وهم حريصون على
إظهار تلك الرعاية ويقدرون
حياتهم ولكن بالنسبة لنا، فإن بلدنا
مليء بالأعذار، ولا توجد أموال
ستكلف ذلك  الكثير هو أن
المال أغلى من حياة الإنسان
وحياة أربعة آلاف من مدن
المواطنين النيجيريين الذين يعيشون في السودان في سبيل
الله
على الرغم من أنه يمكننا القول إننا من
خلفيات فقيرة جميعنا هنا ولكن هذا
ليس سببًا  لكي يتم تجاهلنا،
نحن ندفع لنا حقًا، لقد
بكينا إلى الحد الذي
تعلم فيه أن الدموع لا يمكن أن تخرج بعد الآن، لقد
تقطعت السبل بالجميع
وليس هناك أمل في البقاء على قيد الحياة، الجميع
يركض فقط كيف يتزلج عليها كما تعلم
بحثًا عن مأوى
للبقاء على قيد الحياة وأه هؤلاء هؤلاء
الأشخاص الذين يقاتلون وكأنهم
لا يقدرون أه حياة البشر
إنهم لا يهتمون بأي شخص
ونحن في حالة من
الانهيار
لأنه لا توجد كهرباء
لا يوجد  الماء كان لدي بعض
الماء المتبقي معي كنت
أدير المياه لا أستطيع لمدة يومين لا أستطيع
الاستحمام لا يوجد ماء
للشرب لا يوجد طعام للشرب
لا يمكنك الخروج إلى الشارع للشراء
لا يوجد طعام، لا يوجد شيء يمكنك
شراؤه وحتى النقود ليست موجودة،
أنا دائمًا يقظ طوال الليل،
لا أستطيع النوم،
عقلي ليس في راحة وهؤلاء
الناس مثل الأمس قريبون من المكان الذي
كنت فيه  كان البقاء هناك بمثابة انفجار قنبلة
ولذلك كنت أتوجه عبر النافذة
لأرى ما يحدث بالأسفل،
هؤلاء الجنود يتجولون في
كل مكان ولا تعرف ما إذا
كنت ستكون التالي لأن
الحصبة هي التي تعرفها.  نحن
نسقط الحصبة في كل مكان